I, Joseph
Robinette Biden, Jr.,
do solemnly swear--
SPEAKER:
Think about the challenge
that Biden faces.
He's in adversarial
relationships
from the start.
SPEAKER 2: December, we kept
asking for the plan.
There wasn't a plan.
SPEAKER 3:
Even in that moment
of joy and renewal,
people were extremely
conscious of...
the inheritance we had.
JEN PSAKI:
We were playing catch up
from the moment
the president took office.
It was incredibly
challenging around here.
Don't tell Dr. Fauci
how many pieces of gum
I've swallowed.
SPEAKER 4: This is a period
of remarkable division
in the country.
Delta was raging.
Things were really
falling apart.
It's time to end
the forever war.
SPEAKER 5: Biden's cabinet,
not stupid people,
and they got this
really wrong.
SPEAKER 3:
President Ghani said to me
on the phone,
"I will stay and fight
to the death."
He fled the country
the next day.
SPEAKER 6: The United States
has never seen
an adversary like this
before.
We are in global struggle,
and autocracy's on the rise.
Biden knew the moment
would come
when you would need
old alliances.
That moment came
with Ukraine.
SPEAKER 7:
We began to pick up
a massive Russian
military buildup.
So we go to Moscow quietly.
I found President Putin
to be unapologetic,
and his appetite for risk
has grown.
I conveyed
serious consequences
that would flow from
military aggression.
SPEAKER 8:
The Biden administration
learned from the mistakes
made in Afghanistan.
They responded by getting
out ahead of events
instead
of being behind them.
JOE BIDEN: We're living
at an inflection point
in history.
We're engaged
in a struggle
between democracy
and autocracy.
They're betting
that democracy's days
are numbered.
♪ (DRAMATIC OUTRO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪